this morning on the dish renowned
Chicago chef Paul Kahn born in the Windy
City food was a family business his
father owned both a deli and a salmon
smokehouse in the city's West Loop
neighborhood after college Khan became a
line cook and then a sous chef before
joining with a business partner to open
his first restaurant Blackbird a string
of successes followed Kahn's now the
executive chef and owner of eleven
restaurant concepts including the
publican avec Nico Osteria
and he's won three James Beard Awards
including outstanding chef and Best Chef
in the Midwest and also his first
cookbook
cheers to the publican was just released
Paul Keim good morning welcome to the
dish good morning the gradual ations on
the cookbook that introduction I'm a
little embarrassed feels pretty good I
won't lie chef well all dishes from the
cookbook on the far right would be
cucumbers that are charred and dressed
with something called zhuge it's like a
Middle East cheese list pesto made with
pumpkin seeds more like the archenemy of
Flash Gordon exactly next to that is our
interpretation of Mexican Street corn
which really relies on espelette pepper
or wonderful complex spice from the
Basque Country roasted pork shoulder on
white grits with pistachios and endive
and then a dish made famous by our
former executive chef at the publican
Cosmo gasps barbecued carrots carrots
with something we call Rancho vie
dressing and toasted pecans and then we
have a stack of accolades and waffles
right next to you right yeah from the
very beginning of the dessert that's
most famous there is a really light airy
waffle that has big chunks of pearl
sugar inside of it Wow and what do we
have here that we're going to sample
nothing fancy it's just a delicious
old-fashioned look sample that yeah a
good hour of the morning
perfectly Saturday morning oh my god
nicely diluted a little bit of water
chef you you came to cooking in a fairly
circuitous fashion despite the family
roots the salmon smokehouse
I read that at one point you are a pipe
organ tuner apprentice wow you really
did your research I really did I dug
deep in the archives tell us about that
you know I answered an ad in the paper
when I was a kid I just had a weird slew
of jobs that I learned a lot of great
lessons from one of the interesting
things was the the gentleman that I
tuned pipe organs with we had about 20
in the city of Chicago we'd drive around
either I would be up at the keyboard
pushing the note or I'd be inside of a
chest tapping these little things that
you used to adjust the pitch of each
individual pipe but the funny thing was
this the gentleman would always say okay
we're done where do you want to go for
dinner
or for lunch so we ate Thai food and we
just a lot of ethnic food so yet again
it was a tie into the food business
restaurant apprenticeship you also
studied applied mathematics in college
that didn't go anywhere either
but I use it every day no but as you say
your your father ran a Jewish deli so
you know you mean you essentially had
this from the very beginning yeah I
think what I really have had from the
beginning is the passion you know he
would they had a little smokehouse where
they would smoke chubs I don't know if
you've ever had warm smoked fish most
people haven't had that that pleasure
and especially chubbs are really oily
yeah they're in the herring family and
he just held it out and said you know
eat kid and that was like boom in my
brain this is oh my god this is
incredible
yeah and years later is just like I'm a
garden I love to discover new
ingredients that love to go to farmers
markets so ultimately it was the path
that I chose I have to admit public in
one of your restaurants in Chicago is my
favorite restaurant I think in terms of
vibes and food it can you're not lying
really I'm not lying but each one is
pretty different I mean how did you
develop each concept you know we it's
the same story it all comes from passion
you know a blackbird was sort of guys
that don't know what they're doing
myself and my business partners and we
just dove into it and did it the next
one avec was from Mayan was really all
about the the first time that I went to
Europe and had this great experience
cooking in a hearth sitting around
drinking wine just being with people and
avec kind of seems like a party every
night you sit with people you don't know
I've heard yeah so you've heard you
described yourself as a cook with a
wrestlers mentality well you guys are
great what would that what do you need
you know III wrestled for a large part
of my life and in wrestling it was like
okay get your composure and start
climbing back up the stairs you know
fight back and I think I teach that
lesson to young cooks and managers that
way which is not all easy yeah we're
excited are you about this new
restaurant at Wrigley Field well it's
it's it's another we have a restaurant
called big star I spent time working in
Rick Bayless as kitchens and so it's a
taqueria it's it's a me it's fun I am a
huge Cubs fan
so I'm incredibly excited about it
because our great organization they're
they're great new partners for us well
we are used to the game yeah exactly
okay as I asked you to sign this dish
custom on this part of the program I
will also ask you the question we all
have scholarships which is if you could
share this bounty with any figure past
or present who would it be
they asked me that in the in the back
room and I said as always Keith Richards
there's not a correct oh they're bad as
the next week's answer was Socrates this
week Keith Richards one of the songs I'm
gonna I'm gonna walk before they make me
run there you go
bring it at all homes yes Paul Kahn from
Chicago thank you and for more on Paul
Kahn and the dish head to our website at
CBS this morning calm